axé is a risk-taker
he goes back to this [ __ ] he has devoted
his life to super smash bros melee a
game that could never be a career for
anyone but the world's best weapon is
our evil super smash brothers Bay and he
did it with a character that everyone
said would never be a winner and a lot
of people tell me
Pikachu's not good you have to move on
to a top-tier play like Falco or Marth
or something except everyone was taking
a main is a serious commitment
especially when you end up sticking with
for 13 years
something about Pikachu like the way
that I can move around with him and just
how he is as a character something about
him clicks to me and I don't know why
actually not have realized at the time
but picking Pikachu as his main was a
pretty bold move see the Pokemon was
exclusively relegated to the middle or
even bottom tiers of the community tier
list
Pikachu when I started him was like kind
of in the middle of the tier list but to
me I felt like there was something
really good about Pikachu that people
just didn't quite get pikachu has a lot
of problems when it comes to competitive
melee he struggles to get in on his
opponents he dies extremely quickly to
some of the most common top tiers and
his short range attacks and grabs force
him to take risks to stay in and secure
kills he's a glass cannon winning with
Pikachu basically means hurling yourself
at your opponent over and over again and
hoping you survive
[Music]
Pikachu is a fast killer he can kill
people at really low percent with just a
tail spike or with up smash she has a
strongest up smash in the game and his
recovery is amazing you pretty much
always live with the character if you
know how to recover correctly axes first
tournament back in high school
introduced to into a world of
possibilities he didn't win but from
that moment on he knew that competitive
melee was gonna be more than just a
one-time thing one day I saw an
advertisement in my high school for a
super smash brothers melee tournament
and I entered I got my butt kicked I
learned that I was really bad and I knew
that there was gonna be more tournaments
so I just I just got hooked and I got
drawn into the tournament world and
that's where the whole journey began
Hayley was special it gave acts the
chance to break out of his shell and
connect with the world around him
I feel like melee is kind of like an
outlet for me to express something that
I can't normally express in person you
know I'm usually more laid-back I'm
pretty quiet like to myself but melee is
that one place where I can just let
everything out ackd spent years grinding
tournaments across the u.s. improving
his placements and even sometimes
breaking into top aides but when the
very best were around axe just wasn't
winning see even then melee was a game
dominated by a small collection of top
players known as the five gods some were
able to challenge them but not axe he
was a fan favorite short and
occasionally took games off of them but
he was playing a mid tier character that
just couldn't hang the top tier and that
always meant getting eliminated before
first place
[Music]
but 2014 mark axe and Pikachu's
transformation into a true power
cultivated oh really got spot right now
so what's gonna happen
he gets the up smash he can't believe
that he moves on winners finals to face
hungrybox playing safe thrown out those
Thunderbolts one misty oh my god oh my
god that was so [ __ ] but it wasn't the
best axe advances this man's fun wild
Arizona and shortly after that at Evo
2014 axe made a history for stalking
silent wolf in under a minute
it went down as one of the proudest
moments of his career technical as sound
well the changing Huntsville platforms
can really do a lot i messing him up
potential stock gets the up air tail
spike and suit at that nice wide she'll
not even trying to get she'll snap as
the shields do get really small all
other stock big gotcha
pika pika so that's their percent Oh
commentators curse we learn from trouble
I think you know I've just been a fan of
Team Rocket because that trouble doubled
extremely quit the picture champ is
humongous here oh oh man silent will
we've seen a lot of course sucks on this
stage before but a five seconds Sowell
buddy down to his last stop is he gonna
get up a four minute passes won't let's
see he's right to the edge oh my god
that was emphatic that was amazing
actually becoming more and more of a
crowd favorite but it wasn't just
because of his weird character pic or
his solid play
he became a meme people started
comparing him to Drake and even called
him Walgreen Drake because of his
part-time job boy walk drink just take
care guys thank me later
memes aside though people began to agree
that axe and Pikachu were a perfect
match
no one has done it for as long as he has
outside of like the gods right with
Pikachu which is ridiculous
max I think he's crazy he's like it's a
psycho maniac
Pikachu there's no Pikachu that you can
play against that will prepare you for
him and axes continued success led to a
sponsor upgrade in 2015 he joined tempo
storm I don't know about other people
but I'm melee for life I've never played
another game that feels anywhere near as
good as melee but once again axe was
still losing to that upper echelon of
players but he missed times the up smash
mango able to TECA get out of the danger
zone okay go up smashes axe out of this
tournament top it's just weren't good
enough nothing but first place would do
I've been practicing a ton like a lot a
lot like just a lot of melee you know
people that watch my stream probably see
like me versus vectorman we're doing
like some crazy ridiculous stuff all the
way our practice was really weird but
that's how I play and it's just really
cool to see it paying off and this I see
this sort of as like a stepping stone
going into even more melee tournament
20:19 started out looking like more of
the same for ax he had an incredible
loser's bracket run at genesis but went
out in a close three to two grand finals
I really feel like that last shot game 5
right acts really showing his grit and
his maturity his ability to stay dialed
in for such a long period of time but
that last stock hungrybox had way too
much composure then I'd get on my level
he ran the loser's gauntlet again
beating some of the best players in the
world only to take second acts was
playing out of his mind he could beat
anyone everyone but he always stalled
out engrams
at least until smash summit 8 the smash
summit series of tournaments were
designed to bring together the very best
players in the world to compete and this
tournament was no different axe made it
out of his group with a decent seed but
the bracket stage is where he and
Pikachu bulldozed everyone together they
wrecked rising star Zane annihilated
their a longtime friend and rival mango
one of the gods Oh
[Music]
player in the world the best smack
summit 8 was the first time anyone won a
major with Pikachu and it was the first
time axe won a major at all he was
overcome with emotion I don't know what
to say I just I've been working really
hard for this and I know this is a long
time coming it's just crazy to me axes
historic achievement marked a new era
for melee he finally proven that both he
and Pikachu were championship material
my emotions are going crazy right now
and I don't want this to just be the one
you know what I mean I I feel like
there's a lot more after this so I'm
gonna I'm gonna keep going his hard work
and unfailing devotion to his favorite
character helped them both achieve what
any thought was impossible but that was
just one win one step on their long
journey together
all right all right I'm gonna eat this
pizza I'm out of here
all right man Congrats Pat Summitt ate